You need to understand that
everything you do at the poker
table conveys information.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
You can't be like all loosey-goosey,
having a sandwich,
being on your phone.
Woo-hoo!
Baby, I love it.
There's three basic
characteristics that
make an elite poker player.
One is just the raw skill.
The other is a
fundamental understanding
of the mathematical side.
The third part is what
I call discipline.
In this MasterClass, I'm going
to share things that I've
actually never shared before.
For example, I look at a guy
and say, you've got King Nine.
You're a sick human.
[LAUGHTER]
King Nine!
Well, that's not magic.
It's usually based off
a combination of things.
And I'm going to teach
you how to do that.
I'm going to teach you
tournament strategy,
continuation betting,
picking up tells.
So this tell probably
made me the most money.
The classic chip glance tell.
You notice that?
I see those cards, and my
brain is telling my eyes,
the next thing we've
got to do is bet chips.
Most of the time, it's
totally subconscious.
They don't even know
they're doing it.
Poker is an
intellectual endeavor
that is totally skill-based
in the long run.
A lot of people can
confuse themselves
into thinking that they're
losing because of luck when
it's actually skill.
One of the absolute
best ways to learn
is to go over a hand in
depth in a hand breakdown.
I bet $1,150, and Alec
makes it just $2,500.
I still think his range
can be relatively wide.
Now, on the river, you're pretty
much down to just two options.
Is this a value bet,
or is this a bluff?
There's no such thing
as a value bluff.
OK?
You just didn't know
what you were doing.
You're going to make
a lot of mistakes.
Learning nothing from those
mistakes is the mistake.
And when you feel like
you've got this game mastered
and you've got
nothing left to learn,
that's the exact point
where everyone else
starts to surpass you.
I'm Daniel Negreanu, and
this is my MasterClass.